hey what's up everyone it's marcus
brownlee from mkbhd and today today
we're going to be doing a tutorial on
how to get the itunes visualizer so this
is obviously a tutorial that implies or
that applies to both mac and pc users uh
what we're going to do if you if you
haven't heard of this already i did do
this video earlier and i'll try to post
this as a video response because when i
did this the first time i was using cam
studio so now that i have campaign
studio 6 hopefully this won't be as
framing it'll be good quality and you
can see everything so actually i'm going
to maximize this because the visualizer
does look better maximized
so what you're going to do is obviously
pick a song i'm just gonna play this
soft blues song in the background
and now that the song is actually
playing i don't know if you can hear it
or not we'll see at the end of the
recording
i'm actually in order to choose first of
all the type of visualizer go up here to
the itunes toolbar and go to view
and go to
uh choose the visualizer you can either
choose the itunes visualizer or the
itunes classic visualizer so first of
all we'll see what it looks like when we
use the itunes visualizer just hit show
visualizer and there you go now i
apologize if it is a little bit framing
because the uh the screen recording
won't pick up every frame but that is
what the visualizer looks like so now if
we go and uh hide the visualizer again
and what i'm going to do actually now is
go to video visualizer and go to classic
visualizer so now when we go back up to
view and visualizer you see the options
menu which was grayed out before is
actually open for us to click if i click
it we can say cap first of all display
frame rate and i may or may not um
we can cap the frame rate at 30 frames
per second i'm going to uncheck that
always display song info use directx and
faster but rougher display those are the
options we can choose in the classic
visualizer so now that i hit okay i'm
going to view the classic visualizer
again go to view and show visualizer and
this shortcut is available using control
t
so here is the itunes classic visualizer
obviously these sounds coming out of the
apple logo and it might be a little
framing again but um i hope you do get
the idea that that is how you show the
visualizer itunes so if i pause it you
can see the rings stop really moving all
that much because the sound has stopped
if i hit the play button again
we'll get out of those rings uh
emulating or coming out of the apple
once again
so uh there we go that's how you show
the visualizer i'm going to go ctrl t
here to hide the visualizer and that is
basically it so i hope you like this hd
tutorial i hope it helped you guys if
you were trying to uh get that itunes
visualizer working if you just want to
full screen at a party or a disco jam
whatever you're doing that's how you get
the itunes visualizer
i hope this tutorial was helpful if you
do have any requests feel free to
subscribe and message me and i'll try to
do a request video for you so again this
has been an hd tutorial from mkbhd
thanks for watching peace